i'll show you the scene now because you
can see the road in front of me this is
where the car came down you can see that
the police is still on the scene uh so
other emergency services analyzing what
happened you might be able to see in the
background there there's some salt in
the road the car came down here
behind these police vans there is
actually a body on the road where
someone was hit the car then continued
its journey down and then went on to the
pavement again clipped another car and
then you can see it at the far end where
it's gone through a shop window now the
police have actually moved their cordon
back so we can't bring you right down
there to see that but we're told
by an eyewitness who is on the scene he
was actually driving another car he said
he was clipped by the car going very
fast it hit him on the right hand side
the car then went into the shop window
the man stayed in the car and police
have told us then members of the public
actually apprehended the driver but they
had one of their police officers in this
in the area so he got to the scene very
very quickly
and then the man was arrested as you say
we know it's a 29 year old
german man with dual nationality
we don't know at the moment whether this
was an accident or whether this was a
deliberate attack the police have told
us at least 12 people have been injured
five of those have serious injuries one
person has been confirmed dead already
but this is an extremely sensitive area
for berliners because it's just around
the corner here that in 2016
there was a terror attack at a christmas
market where a vehicle drove into
people at the christmas market
killing 13 so you can imagine when the
news came
this morning that people had been hit by
a car berlin is very very worried but as
i say at the moment we do not know
whether this was a deliberate attack